we've always been a bit unlucky about
the reaction of caesium and water we
played it several times it's meant go
explosively but always it's been a bit
of a disappointment sometimes of real
disappointment we decided we would try a
quick experiment to see caesium reacting
with water using a high-speed camera
this is just a quick demonstration to
see what happens this is not a carefully
controlled scientific experiment of
course it's controlled so it's safe but
we haven't fixed every parameter in the
way that you would do if you were doing
a carefully adjusted experiment
because high-speed filming needs very
bright lights the heat of the light made
sure the cesium which has a low melting
point was nicely liquid before we broke
the ampoule when you break the ampoule
the shock of breaking it broke up the
cesium into quite a few little droplets
and you can see these droplets spreading
out and falling towards the water what
was surprising that you can see these
individual droplets of metal have a
vapor trail they're clearly reacting
with something in the air
it could be with the oxygen but we think
it's probably due to the water vapor
with the hot lamps there's quite a lot
of vapor coming from the water so the
reaction between cesium and water begins
in the gas phase with essentially the
water vapor that is above it and then
when these droplets hit the water each
of the droplets starts reacting quite
violently it's important to stress that
reactions between molten metals and
water are very well studied there are
whole series of papers I've got one here
which Brady likes first of all because
it's from the journal Nature the reason
he likes it is it from 1973 three years
before he was born
now of course I'm a chemist so we come
back to the chemistry and caesium
reacting the water should make the water
alkaline because we're making caesium
hydroxide caesium plus ions Oh H minus
ions and therefore the water should be
alkaline so you might ask yourself what
would have happened if we had put an
indicator into the water before we did
the explosion so we only thought about
it afterwards but luckily we still had
rubidium to react so we have tried
rubidium with an indicator keep watching
to see what happened for us you may have
seen videos on the internet where people
say their reactions of cesium and I've
been told on quite good authority that
occasionally rubidium has reacted better
and they've switched the film so what is
labeled cesium on the film may actually
be rubidium we get lots and lots of
emails from our viewers and we try our
best to answer atleast some of them but
some of them make points which are quite
difficult to explain why they're wrong
without pages of explanation and we're
not experts in some of these fields
anyway but if you send us an email and
we don't respond this is not because
we're ignoring what you're saying but
just because we're human and we can't
answer everything